Speaker 1: OK. In the meantime, this
you really have to see this weekend in
Florida was the opening night of
the much promoted and hyped tour
Speaker 2: of disgraced former
Speaker 1: Fox News superhero Bill O'Reilly,
interviewing disgraced former President
Donald Trump. It was half empty.
Speaker 2: I mean, a genuine embarrassment
Speaker 1: in this picture from the opening night
in Sunrise, Florida. You can see that the floor
seats are about 40 percent empty. Then they
announced before the show started. If you have
cheap seats in the upper decks, we're going to
close the upper decks, come on down and sit in the
lower level for free. You don't even have to pay
anything extra. Sales were so terrible that
tickets were available right up until the show
Speaker 2: started for $3
Speaker 1: per ticket in many sections.
Day two not much better. We have
a video of the event right before
it started and, as you can see, are very,
Speaker 2: very light turnout on the way out.
Speaker 1: Some hilarious interviews with
people. Here's an interview with a woman
who went to the event and she said, You
know, I love Trump as much as anybody.
But he kind of goes off on tangents and repeats
Speaker 2: things that we already know.
Speaker 7: Well, I thought Bill did an
excellent job of trying to steer the
questions that he had prepared to more of an
historical nature because it's very difficult.
I love President Trump, but he can't go a bit off
on tangents and perhaps repeat some of the things
that we all know. But Bill tried to make it a
little different and make it more of a history
Speaker 2: of
Speaker 1: imagine trying to ask Trump historical
Speaker 2: questions.
Speaker 1: He knows nothing about
history. He barely even understand,
Speaker 2: like he's been tricked
Speaker 1: into thinking certain countries
that don't exist are countries. Remember
when he mispronounced countries that
don't exist, African countries, etc.?
Speaker 2: Here's another interview
Speaker 1: with a guy leaving the show
Speaker 2: this I don't know if this
Speaker 1: was the Sunday show or the
night before. He says the media covered up all of
the good things Trump did, so it was good to hear
it from Trump directly. You can imagine what that
sounded like. And he also said it was great that
Bill O'Reilly was the interviewer because Bill
O'Reilly is a centrist who doesn't take sides.
Speaker 2: Are you familiar
Speaker 1: with Bill O'Reilly, dude?
Speaker 2: Take a look.
Speaker 5: You said you don't have a
truly fair time in office? No, we heard
more of the negative stuff on media.
You know, we never heard the good stuff he was
doing. And so it's really good to hear from a
person like Bill O'Reilly, who is very
middle of the road. Here they pick
Speaker 1: sides. Is this guy really unaware? I
mean, he looks young. Maybe he really doesn't know
that Bill O'Reilly was for a time the
most prominent conservative on Fox News.
He ultimately lost his show. Sexual harassment
allegations all sorts of horrible stuff, but
for like twenty years or eighteen years, he was
the top conservative voice of Fox News and was
considered up there with Rush Limbaugh doesn't
take sides. I mean, it's just a fantasy world. So
what can we read into the lack of turnout? I
would read very little into it, quite frankly.
I think the reason that a lot of people didn't
go to this show is number one. Early on, even
cheap seats were selling for 100 bucks. A lot of
people just don't have that kind of money to go,
sit in the nosebleeds and listen to Trump, talk
Speaker 2: to Bill O'Reilly. So I think
Speaker 1: the early pricing was a factor, too.
You can love Trump and hate Democrats and plan
to vote for Trump and just be tired of hearing
the same nonsense from him over and over again.
So the very same people who might just get bored
Speaker 2: at his rallies. We covered
Speaker 1: Trump's rallies when he did them,
Speaker 2: and even the people
Speaker 1: on the stage were bored. You
would have a guy checking his phone,
tapping his wife, clearly saying, Can we go? Some
people would fall asleep, others would just leave.
You can be bored by that. They're still
voting for Trump at the end of the day. So I
Speaker 2: don't think the lack of turnout
Speaker 1: is a sign that we can safely
look away from the threat of what might happen
in twenty two and 24 and say, we don't have to
worry about these Trump wins. I think we do. But
it's also really boring to listen to Trump. Repeat
the same thing hour after hour after hour. I think
that's as far as I would go in reading into this.